I can't do the scream right now I can't
really scream right now cuz I have a
sore throat but you want to know why I'm
trying to scream Fandango and slash are
looking for the ultimate screamer if you
think you have what it takes upload a
video of yourself screaming to the
hashtag Fandango scream contest on
twitter or instagram at Fandango on
Halloween night the winner will be
decided and they will win a free trip to
the haunted Stanley Hotel aka the
inspiration of the shining
so I'm wearing a Jurassic Park t-shirt
in my trailer review for Godzilla
because I just had to I loved Jurassic
Park the new Godzilla film just got its
first official trailer and this thing is
being yanked off the internet left and
right people are taking it down but I'm
kind of excited for this film for a few
reasons
one America has already tried to make it
Godzilla film and failed horribly so
that's kind of a lesson learned
situation where I'm hoping that they can
be like yes we tried that before and
what we got was Hank Azaria and some
girl with crazy hair trying to be a news
reporter and Matthew Broderick wasn't it
it was a comedy the movie was a comedy I
loved it when I was a kid because I was
like 10 when it came out but it's bits
horrible this new one looks like they're
taking it in a much cooler route for one
it has Bryan Cranston and Aaron
taylor-johnson in it which is two pluses
in my book especially Cranston that guy
adds legitimacy to like anything he
could do a commercial for peanut butter
and jelly and you'd be like I'm riveted
but this trailer has an interesting
voiceover in it one that you might be
surprised to learn is actually from an
interview from J robert Oppenheimer the
creator of the atomic bomb that adds a
bit of a creepiness to that trailer
doesn't it when you think about that and
that also adds something to this trailer
that I hope is in the movie and that is
a more important realistic end of the
world devastation type vibe and that's
the kind of thing that was in the
original Godzilla king of monsters or
Gojira the Japanese film it had this
very like we could all die type of
feeling to it it wasn't just a guy in a
rubber suit going
and Raymond Burr was not in it but I
just had this tone to it that was
slightly more serious despite the dated
special effects where you felt like you
know people are actually gonna die this
isn't just some fun whimsical sci-fi
fantasy comedy like the 1998 film but we
do get our first official look at
Godzilla in this it's a little dark it's
kind of a silhouette but I'm excited I
think it looks awesome I'm hoping that
it can be a really fun movie but at the
same time the type of film where you
actually feel as if there is some
investment in the human characters it's
not just a oh boy look there's Godzilla
running around slapping helicopters like
you actually care about the people
involved not just I can't wait to see
Godzilla because there's a big CGI thing
and he's gonna blow up a lot of stuff
I'm hoping that you care about the
people
so you'll care more about the creature
and the things that are going on what do
you guys think of this trailer
let me know below and as always guys
thanks very much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck on eyes